vamos a aplicar nuestra definición de
carga formal a otro tipo de moléculas y
donde tengamos otro tipo de átomos así
que veamos primero en moléculas que
incluyen oxígeno así que digamos que
estamos tratando de calcular la carga
formal para el oxígeno en esta molécula
tenemos el oxígeno con unido a esta
estructura ok de carbonos y hay que
decir cuántos electrones hay alrededor
de este oxígeno que estén libres y
digamos que tenemos esta estructura
entonces vamos a empezar checando el
número de electrones de valencia del
oxígeno por supuesto para esto vamos a
para poder calcular la carga formal
vamos a hacer más claro qué tipo de
electrones hay en estos enlaces y como
el oxígeno se encuentra en el grupo 6 de
la tabla periódica pues podemos asegurar
que tiene entonces 6 electrones de
valencia muy bien entonces ahora nos
fijamos en el número de electrones
presentes
the door del átomo verdad nos fijamos en
el número de electrones y vemos que son
6 libres y 1 del enlace así que tenemos
7 por lo tanto esto nos da una carga
negativa entonces recordemos que en un
enlace covalente tenemos un electrón del
carbono y un electrón del oxígeno muy
bien entonces a qué conclusión llegamos
a que este oxígeno tiene una carga
negativa muy bien así que la tendencia
será que siempre que veas un oxígeno con
un enlace y tres pares solitarios de
electrones sabrás entonces que tiene una
carga formal de menos 1 una carga formal
negativa vamos a hacer otro ejemplo que
involucre oxígeno digamos ahora tenemos
un oxígeno que está unido con dos
enlaces o digamos con un enlace doble
verdad entonces digamos es esta
estructura vamos a poner estos
electrones para que sea un poco más
claro y alrededor de este oxígeno vamos
a completar la regla
el octeto y ahí lo tienen entonces
nuevamente el oxígeno tiene 6 electrones
de valencia ahora cuántos electrones
tenemos alrededor de este átomo pues
tenemos dos pares
libres que son cuatro más estos dos son
6 por lo tanto tenemos 0 como carga
formal muy bien tenemos una carga formal
cero
así que ahora que veas que un oxígeno
con un enlace doble y dos pares
solitarios de electrones entonces podrás
pensar para ti mismo que eso tiene una
carga formal cero y recuerda todo eso
solo viene con la práctica ahora hagamos
un último ejemplo con oxígeno bueno nada
un último vamos a hacer otro más tenemos
ahora un oxígeno que está unido a un
carbono a través de un enlace doble
verdad y otra estructura y digamos ahora
que no tiene estos dos pares solitarios
de electrones sino que tiene un enlace
con un hidrógeno ok entonces ponemos los
electrones estos electrones y para
completar la regla vamos a poner un par
de electrones solitarios entonces el
oxígeno tiene una tiene 6 electrones de
valencia y en este caso tenemos cuántos
electrones alrededor del oxígeno pues
tenemos estos 3 y estos dos son 5 por lo
tanto tenemos una carga positiva
y tenemos nuevamente el patrón siempre
que tengamos oxígeno con tres enlaces
con tres enlaces y un par de electrones
solitarios va a tener una carga formal
de más 1 muy bien entonces vamos a ver
ahora un ejemplo donde nos den la carga
formal nos den la carga formal y
nosotros tengamos que encontrar el
número de electrones alrededor del
oxígeno ok entonces digamos que tenemos
esta estructura de anillo muy bien
tenemos esta estructura de anillo unido
a un grupo digamos que sea o h 2 muy
bien entonces tenemos esta estructura y
vamos a y nos dicen vamos a suponer que
nos dicen que esto tiene una carga
positiva
aquí era una carga positiva entonces
vamos a suponer que nos dicen que esto
tiene una carga positiva y esto tenemos
como vimos en el vídeo anterior dos
formas de resolverlo una de ellas por
ejemplo si extendemos
esta estructura tenemos nuestro oxígeno
unido a dos hidrógenos bien tenemos esta
estructura unida a dos hidrógenos
entonces a partir de esto como el
oxígeno está en el segundo periodo debe
seguir la regla del octeto verdad
entonces debe tener 8 electrones
alrededor de él y aquí tenemos 6 verdad
por 3 3 enlaces covalentes entonces nos
faltan 2
si nos falta un par de electrones
solitarios y este es digamos la forma
rápida y se puede verificar en que en
efecto tenemos una carga positiva verdad
vamos a tener justo una carga positiva
porque son 6 electrones de valencia y
son 5 alrededor del oxígeno ahora la
forma digamos
y quizás un poco más complicada es
nuevamente si extendemos esto
bien digamos tenemos aquí nuestro
oxígeno y déjenme poner estos electrones
lo mismo para los enlaces con el
hidrógeno
ok tenemos dos hidrógenos y entonces
sabemos que en condiciones normales el
oxígeno tendría seis electrones tendría
seis electrones muy bien tenemos seis
electrones pero tiene este oxígeno tiene
una carga positiva quiere decir que
perdimos perdimos un electrón verdad
entonces en este caso debe tener cinco
electrones ahora bien si aquí tenemos
tres cuantos nos faltan para tener cinco
pues justamente dos y que vienen en un
par solitario verdad entonces ahí lo
tienen ya tienen dos formas de encontrar
cuántas parejas de electrones solitarios
hay en el oxígeno vamos a hacer ahora un
ejemplo utilizando halógenos aunque y
vamos a calcular la carga formal para un
halógeno y vamos a elegir el cloro
digamos vamos a tomarnos solo él
nos tomamos el cloro y el cloro se
encuentra en el grupo 7 de la tabla
periódica verdad entonces de hecho va a
saber muchos mecanismos en química
orgánica donde los los halógenos están
rodeados por 8 electrones entonces vamos
a hacer primero ese ejemplo donde
tenemos un halógeno rodeado de 8
electrones y como el cloro se encuentra
en el grupo 7 de la tabla periódica
orgánica entonces normalmente tendría 7
electrones verdad 7 electrones de
valencia ahora bien tenemos 8 electrones
alrededor del cloro y esto nos da una
carga formal de menos 1 quiere decir que
este cloro tiene una carga negativa
verdad
y cuando los halógenos tienen una carga
negativa son relativamente estables él
simplemente ganan un electrón así que
son como un gas noble así que los
halógenos son muy electro negativos y
son capaces de son capaces de
proporcionar una carga negativa muy
fácilmente muy bien ahora vamos a hacer
un ejemplo más un ejemplo grande en
donde involucremos un montón de átomos
de los que hemos estado hablando
para calcular cargas formales así que
vamos a dibujar la estructura del
nitrometano ok vamos a trabajar con el
nitro metano y como dice metano eso
probablemente quiere decir bueno de
hecho si tiene quiere decir que sólo
tiene un carbono verdad entonces
pintamos un carbono y el metano
comúnmente tendría cuatro hidrógenos
pero en este caso sólo vamos a poner
tres en este caso sería como un grupo
metilo verdad entonces de una vez vamos
poniendo los electrones
la otra parte del nombre del nitrometano
viene justamente del grupo nitro y el
grupo nitro justamente es cuando el
cuarto enlace del carbono lo ponemos
unido a un nitrógeno y este nitrógeno va
con un enlace doble a un oxígeno un
oxígeno y con un enlace simple a un
oxígeno muy bien entonces ponemos los
electrones solo para hacer más fáciles
las cuentas y vamos a completar la regla
del octeto para el oxígeno ok vamos a
poner estos dos pares de electrones
solitarios alrededor de este y aquí
necesitamos 33 pares de electrones en el
oxígeno muy bien entonces vamos a ir
trabajando la carga formal de cada una
de estas moléculas digamos que empezamos
con el carbono el carbono tiene 4
electrones de valencia muy bien mientras
que alrededor de este carbono tenemos 4
electrones verdad entonces restamos 4 y
tiene una carga
neutra tiene tiene carga formal 0 ahora
pensemos en alguno de estos hidrógenos
digamos en estos hidrógenos pensemos por
ejemplo en este el hidrógeno tiene un
electrón de valencia verdad y en este
caso está rodeado de solo un electrón
así que tiene una carga formal cero y lo
mismo puede aplicar para estos otros dos
así que eso pasa para estos tres
hidrógenos ahora bien qué ocurre con el
nitrógeno el nitrógeno tiene 5
electrones de valencia pero alrededor de
este solo podemos encontrar 44
electrones de valencia así que este
perdón 4 electrones alrededor del
nitrógeno así que este nitrógeno tiene
una carga positiva muy bien el nitrógeno
tiene una carga positiva muy bien vamos
a ver qué ocurre con este oxígeno de
aquí con este oxígeno de aquí el oxígeno
tiene 6 electrones de valencia pero
presentes alrededor de él hay
6 por lo tanto tenemos una carga neutra
una carga formal de 0 ahora bien con
este último oxígeno el oxígeno de aquí
abajo tenemos 6 electrones de valencia
pero alrededor de él tenemos
y electrones por lo tanto nos da una
carga formal de menos 1 entonces este
oxígeno tiene una carga negativa
así que ya hemos calculado la carga
formal de todos estos átomos en esta
molécula un químico probablemente haría
todo esto mucho más corto lo simplificar
y ahí no dibujar ya todo todo este es
tamaño verdad simplemente diría bueno
vamos a poner nuestro grupo metilo que
tenemos aquí el ch3 muy bien unido a
nuestro nitrógeno y este nitrógeno va a
tener una carga positiva verdad y como
va a estar unido pues va a estar unido a
un oxígeno a través de un doble enlace y
a un oxígeno a través de un enlace
sencillo simple pero que tiene una carga
negativa muy bien así que estas dos
estructuras contienen la misma
información verdad pero de esta forma
digamos es es un poco más rápida de leer
y de dibujar que una estructura de
puntos para el nitrometano así que esto
además añade toda la información de la
carga formal así que para eso vas a
necesitar mucha práctica sobre la carga
forma
si es que quieres aprender sobre
mecanismos de química orgánica